Speaker 1: I want to look again at one of the
false notions that is being spread by the right
when the topic of cannabis, of marijuana comes
up. This is sort of like a perfect storm of a
bunch of different stories. First of all, the clip
we're going to look at is from Fox and Friends.
Fox and Friends has been, I guess you could say,
applauded a little bit in the last week because
Steve Doocy has started to say, get the vaccine
if you can get it. And there are people saying,
oh, Fox and Friends now is pro vaccine. As we've
said before, Brian Kilmeade on Fox and Friends has
not changed his mind, apparently on vaccines or
whatever the case may be. So let's kind of dampen
our praise of Fox and Friends. Second issue, the
story of increased violent crime in the United
States through the pandemic, which right wing
media wants to exclusively blame on Joe Biden,
even though the increase in crime actually
started under Trump's watch during the pandemic.
And then, number three, any opportunity
to criticize marijuana or cannabis,
depending on how you prefer to refer to it,
they take advantage of that. And in this
particular clip, Fox News suggests violent
crime is up because of people smoking pot.
Take a listen to this. When you
Speaker 2: walk out on the streets
of New York City, you said it smells
Speaker 3: like urine and pot.
OK, not a great morning show, but it's true.
Speaker 2: But the pot part is particularly
important because it after the shooting
in Washington, D.C. on Thursday night,
on Friday, the chief cop in Washington,
D.C., made a connection that too few
leaders in Democratic run
towns are doing, and that
is he finds a direct connection between the
violence, why and pot usage. Why is Robert Contee?
We have taken on the mindset that marijuana is
not really it's not really a big issue in our
city. I can tell you that marijuana undoubtedly
is connected to violent crimes that we're seeing
in our community. When you have something where
people get high reward, they can make a lot of
money by selling illegal marijuana and the risk
is low. The risk for accountability is very low,
debt creates a very, very, very, very, very bad
situation because those individuals get robbed,
those individuals get shot at, those individuals
get involved in disputes all across our city. I'm
seeing it happen more and more. And he's not alone
in other cities are doing as well. But what are
they going to do? It's hard to put the toothpaste
back in the tube. They legalize pot in a bunch of
places and now they've seen violent crime spike.
You're going to say, you know what? We made a
mistake. Well, they should, because obviously,
yeah, the chief's numbers support what he said.
Speaker 3: I'm really glad that the chief brought
this up because it's a very touchy topic because
pot has just been so normalized in our culture.
But he brings up the point that there is a nexus
between pot and violent crime. And it's not just
the buying and selling. You know, it has mental
health effects. You have a higher chance of
schizophrenia, of having psychosis. I mean,
there's actual data behind that. People ignore
that. And the pot lobby is very powerful. It is
very powerful. And and and they're normalizing
it with our children. If you come out against it,
you're just an old fuddy duddy.
Speaker 2: Well, and what the chief said,
he said, look, there are people who are being
robbed to fight to get the money to buy more pot.
Right. Senator Schumer tries is
going to try to make it become in.
Speaker 1: OK, so so they're mixing up like
three different issues. It all kind of feels
like Reefer Madness 20, 21. So so let's
kind of go through these things one by one.
First of all, is the effect of the cannabis on
individual's propensity to be violent. That's
you might be confused and saying what is the
argument? Is the argument about the illegal drug
trade or is it about consumption of cannabis?
They're mixing it all together. First of all,
marijuana doesn't make people violent.
As a general rule. Alcohol often does,
which is completely legal. Alcohol is
actually a major factor in violent crime.
Marijuana is not. There's a very interesting
study called subjective aggression during alcohol
and cannabis intoxication before and after
aggression, exposure. What the study did was
it exposed people to aggression through something
called point, subtraction, aggression, paradigm
and the single category implicit association
test. You don't need to know what that is,
but the findings here are that, quote, subjective
aggression significantly increased following
aggression, exposure in all groups while being
sober, alcohol intoxication, increased subjective
aggression, whereas cannabis decreased the
subjective aggression following aggression,
exposure, aggressive responses. During the peace,
Sape increased following alcohol and decreased
following cannabis relative to placebo. What
this is telling us is that when people are sober
and you do what's called aggression, exposure in a
way that that has been scientifically determined,
this is how you sort of like trigger can
trigger an aggression response from people.
People's level of aggression goes up. Alcohol
is an aggravating factor in generating that
aggression. Aggressive response. Cannabis is a
mitigating factor. So that's one piece. And that's
really important to understand so that, you know,
when they talk about cannabis and making people
violent, it's like, hey, look, maybe look at rock
and roll as well. Like it again, it just feels
like a 40 year old argument that's been widely
debunked. Aside from the pharmacological impact,
there's the other side of it, which is that
legalization reduces violence, it reduces
violence. It is far less likely that there will be
violence when buying pot at a hipster weed store
compared to in a back alley from street dealers
that you don't know. Now, their argument is
if the penalties for the dealing go down, then you
are going to see more dealers enter the market.
But it's not actually working that way because
when it's legalized and regulated, the demand for
buying from street dealers goes down dramatically.
Now, will some people want to pay less even when
there's legalization, to go and buy from a
street dealer who doesn't have to pay? Yeah,
to some degree. But the net effect is a reduction
in cannabis distribution related violence. And
then lastly, how do you not mention three hundred
and fifty million guns in the United States when
you look at all of these other countries that have
decriminalized legalized marijuana and you look at
the United States, you would immediately notice
350 million guns in the United States. That's
not a factor. But somehow the weed is the factor.
You got to be just kidding me with this stuff. And
it's unfortunate because, again, there's people
who want to be told this is really dangerous.
And so they see this and they agree with it.
At the end of the day, where do. You worry
more about violence, the bar down the street or a
room full of stoners playing video games. I mean,
it's a silly way to sort of go to the fundamentals
of this. But think about that and then look at the
placebo controlled studies, including the one that
I mentioned earlier. These people make no sense.
They are looking for an explanation for their
preexisting views rather than actually being open
to following the science. We'll have more on
this story on The David Pakman Show Instagram
find The David Pakman Show. You can
find me on Instagram at David Pakman